what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
it's so I'm gonna be really honest with
you guys I'm really nervous about
starting Jeff Jones green lantern run
I'm not even a hundred percent sure I
want to do it because for a couple of
reasons one because be did an amazing
job and it's like how do you how do you
do something that compares to something
that awesome I mean it's just like damn
you know is following up to a really
amazing run but at the same time
Jeff jobs green lantern is so good like
it's so amazing and it's just the slow
bill to something spectacular and then
it just keeps getting good after that
and so it's like God Nevin you know I'm
so nervous about that plus it's to my
estimations cuz I was going through and
I literally went through all the stories
I've put them in an Excel spreadsheet to
see how long it would take for me to go
from Green Lantern rebirth all the way
up to Godhead would take about 80 videos
that's a year and a half worth of videos
one video a week that's all it's just
like god it's such a huge undertaking
but what I do want to do is I want to
have this video out there because this
is like Kyle Rayner becomes God Flight
Superman which is one part of this but
this is gonna serve as like a
straightforward explanation and the
reason why is because I was going
through forums I was looking up
information the one thing that a lot of
people didn't seem to be able to provide
the answer to is what happens between
Emerald Twilight and Green Lantern
rebirth with regards to the return of
Kilowog the return of the Green Lantern
Corps the recreation of OA you know all
that kind of look how does all that come
into play what bridges those gaps this
video is gonna serve to answer that
question so for like 30 years from the
1960s to the 1990s DC could not get
anybody to care about Hal Jordan it was
like pulling teeth to get people to read
Hal Jordan comics no matter what DC did
people just didn't care and there was a
reason for that I mean you had to
Superman off into space if Superman was
in space fighting evil and so on and so
forth and he had a very intriguing
rogues gallery Brainiac Darkseid Lex
Luthor villains that stand the test of
time Hal Jordan had like Sinestro you
know and Hal Jordans weakness was the
color yellow it was just the yellow
impurity this was back before geoff
johns retcon of parallax all that kind
of stuff but back then it was just the
yellow impurity and so Sinestro's yellow
ring was like the only thing that could
beat Hal Jordan and all you would do is
just see those two finding one another
other than that it was him creating like
wrenches and boxing gloves and stuff
like that with his constructs and it
just wasn't interesting there actually
came up
point where DC took green arrow who was
struggling as well and they've basically
brought him and Hal Jordan together and
they gave us Green Lantern green arrow
and it worked out really well for a time
we got stories like snow birds don't fly
Dennis O'Neil Neal Adams had an
incredible run there the issue was that
with the popularity DC basically removed
Oliver Queen gave him his own stories
which eventually led into longbow
hunters as part of vertigo
they went into my girls run and it was
really really popular Hal Jordan sunk it
slow DC I think actually rolled him over
as a backup feature in flash but it went
this way forever and ever and ever and
ever
and so in the early 1990s DC sat down
and they said okay look here's the deal
we're killing Superman so let's use this
to set the stage to fix a lot of issues
and what I mean by that is the crises
DC's had crises sound a lot more
complicated than they are here is the
quick 15-second super easy to understand
explanation of how the crises work in DC
Comics the flash you know flash of two
worlds whatever issue that was from
Barry Allen's run that introduced the
multiverse it became too difficult too
convoluted to understand crisis on
Infinite Earths got rid of the
multiverse and it created one single
universe there were continuity issues
zero hour crisis and time blinked that
universe out of existence and brought it
back Infinite Crisis reintroduced the
multiverse final crisis made the heroes
aware of the fact that the multiverse
exists those are the crises of DC Comics
now did you really think it'd be that
easy to understand cuz it is it's that
super simple people just look at it in
terms like the multiverse
but setting the stage for the removal of
Hal Jordan here's what DC did DC said
okay some Superman's gonna be killed off
we're gonna have an event called reign
of the Superman Superboy's steel
Eradicator cyborg superman cyborg
superman will be the main bad guy now
we're gonna have cyborg superman along
with some of the villain named Mangal
show up to coast city which is Hal
Jordans hometown while Hal Jordans off
in space and they're going to obliterate
it so they wipeout Coast City Hal Jordan
comes home he realizes the city's been
destroyed while he's in mourning he
recreates it using his power ring the
guardians of the universe chastise him
for using his ring for selfish purposes
they call him back to OA for the purpose
of basically stripping him of his
abilities Hal Jordan fries he takes off
into space
he fights a brunt of the Green Lantern
Corps kills them all takes the Rings
ghost to OA kills all the guardians of
the universe with the exception of
gantlet who survived Hal Jordan didn't
know about that he fights a nest ro
kills him he fights Kilowog kills him he
absorbs all the power in the central
battery core which is basically the main
source of the Green Lantern's power
calls himself parallax and goes on a
rampage now with gantlet surviving he
takes what's left of Hal Jordans
original power ring which has basically
been destroyed he flies to earth he
restores it he gives it to Kyle Rayner
Kyle Rayner becomes the new Green
Lantern now this sets the stage for
Emerald Twilight crisis in time which is
basically just Hal Jordan trying to
recreate the universe in the end Hal
Jordan kind of comes to his senses and
he basically starts you know going
through and writing all these wrongs and
then eventually it leads to Hal Jordan
being removed he merges with the spectre
yadda yadda yadda Kyle Rayner is the
main Green Lantern now now with Kyle
Rayner is a Green Lantern vol 3 keeps on
going except issue number 50 officially
I think maybe assisted number 51
officially picked up with Kyle Rayner as
a Green Lantern but instead of like
recreating everything DC says okay guys
here's the deal
give fans an idea what to expect with
Kyle Rayner so he's making these really
elaborate constructs and fans love it
they're just like this is awesome this
is so much better than Hal Jordan making
a boxing glove so they're like alright
we are down with this now
from 1994 going into really 2001 2002
the landscape for Kyle Rayner was
largely just this idea of let's have a
meal on the Justice League that's
happening fight alongside superheroes
people need a strong understanding but
by the time 2002 came around DC said
okay let's go ahead and start moving
things into the right
of returning car aenor to the
traditional Green Lantern mythos which
means the reformation of OA the return
of the Green Lantern Corps so on and so
forth so enter Joe Kelly so Joe Kelly
sits down and writes a story called
Green Lantern legacy the final will and
testament of Hal Jordan and all this is
is a story told from the perspective of
a guy named Tom and Tom was basically
the mechanic of Hal Jordan he was one of
his closest friends and he was never a
Green Lantern although it was teased
that he was supposed to be but there's
also this little kid named Marty who
looks strikingly similar to Hal Jordan
and claims to be his son and so what
happens is there's this dark Lantern
that basically is running around as
attacking Marty Tom's trying to get out
of the way eventually it's revealed that
the dark Lantern is actually Kilowog and
so what happens is the last will and
testament of how Jordan was if something
happens to me it's likely because I just
became a really bad guy or did something
crazy and so the ring is used to
basically recreate OA and restore
Kilowog now as it stands right now with
regards to the end of Green Lantern
legacy there's Kilowog there's gantlet
as the last guardian of the universe and
there's OA and that's it there's nothing
else so then what happens is Jed when it
comes back and he writes a story where
Kyle Rayner becomes God
he basically adopts the name Ayane this
was really really cool because it was
all about Kyle Rayner just like
overcoming his greatest fear but
essentially what happens is Kyle Rayner
is presented with two scenarios by Hal
Jordan acting is the specter Hal Jordan
says either you can go through door a
and it'll take you back to the moment
when you became the Green Lantern and
you cannot be the Green Lantern you can
just intervene you can kill gantlet you
can tell yourself don't take the ring
you can change your entire history and
live your life as you wanted to if you
go through door B you will basically
become what I should have been and
that's what I on was I on is what Hal
Jordan would have been had he not become
parallax if he had absorbed the entirety
of the central power battery and become
a good guy then he would have been ion
Kyle Rayner chooses door B he basically
takes all the power of the central power
battery and becomes ion what this does
is it allows him to just be everywhere
at once that's literally where the story
is like he's talking to his girlfriend
the daughter of Alan Scott the first
Green Lantern who's tied into mysticism
and so on but he's talking to her and
he's like I'm everywhere like I'm in
Uganda I'm on a planet on the other side
of the galaxy I'm 40 blocks away
fighting criminals I have the power of
God the issue with this is that he
eventually sits down and talks to
Superman and super
says what you have is too much power not
because I think you're a bad guy you're
gonna do anything with it I mean Carlina
is a good guy he's using it for good
purposes what Superman says is because
people view you as a god and what will
start out as admiration will eventually
turn into worship now of course what
Kyle Rayner does is he turns the tables
on Superman and says yeah but people
have cults dedicated to you and they see
you as a god as Superman says yes but
that was developed over the course of
years you've been ion for like four days
and people already see you as God and so
eventually what Kyle Rayner does is he
sits and says yeah this is just too much
power for any one person to have I don't
need this and so at the end of the power
of ions store he basically cast aside
the power of ion but in the process he
essentially goes to OA
to the central power battery that still
remains dormant because he has all the
energy inside he recharges the central
power battery and then that ends up
bringing back the guardians of the
universe because their essences were
directly tied to the battery itself
because they're immortal they're not
indestructible it's just if they die
their essences will just live on until
they can be given physical bodies again
they all come back as little kids
they're left to gantlet Gandil is the
one that trains them and what this does
is this leads directly into green
lantern rebirth and it leads into Green
Lantern vol 1 by Geoff Johns after
rebirth which we'll get into you know in
the next video but that's essentially
how all that stuff comes together that's
how all that stuff works is uh you know
it all kind of goes from one thing to
the next but I felt like this video
needed to be made because I felt like
there were a lot of people out there who
were kind of curious you know if they go
and read Green Lantern rebirth which is
Hal Jordan coming back to life and then
they read Green Lantern vol 1 called no
fear suddenly Kilowog is there suddenly
a new Green Lantern Corps is being
created and no one knows where all that
came from where did I will come from how
- Kilowog come back to life out of the
guardians of the the universe come back
to life how does all that happen
hopefully this video answers those
questions for you guys now hope you get
you circulated around I might posted on
the DC subreddit so that people know
what's going on there's a lot of Green
Lantern fans out there who might be kind
of confused but if you guys are new here
to come as explained if you guys enjoyed
this video be sure to hit the like
button and be sure to sub and yeah let
me know because I imagine a lot of you
guys are like yeah you should cover the
Green Lantern mythos like I said I'm
nervous
I mean I don't know if I should I don't
know if it's if he's even worth giving
it a shot I guess you miss 100% of the
shots you don't take so maybe I should
you know go with it but uh in the event
yeah I will uh I'll catch you guys later
peace
[Music]